big announcement by luther ai releasing
gpt neox20b this is a 20 billion
parameter large language model and it
will be publicly released in about a
week from now so less than a week from
when you're seeing this we have a blog
post right now so there will also be a
paper coming up the blog post details a
little bit about the effort a little bit
about the model and releases some
results on language modeling tasks and
on factual knowledge tasks where the
model compares pretty good pretty well
against comparable bass lines not as
good as something like gpd3 which of
course is 10 times larger but it holds
up quite well and now i'm happy to
welcome connor leahy who is one of the
founding members of luther ai and worked
on gpt new x20b over the last months and
even years i guess and we'll see what he
has to say about it cool hey everyone
today i have with me here connor leahy
who is one of the team members founding
members of the luther ai and creators of
gpt neo20 gpt neo x 20b model uh connor
welcome
thanks for having me on the show
it's really cool i saw the announcement
and
let's this is a big release right
yeah so this uh whole thing was
definitely like a year in the making
overall so we first started seriously
working on you know larger model like
this with core weave around yeah about a
year ago it's like probably like last
february maybe um in march we had like
starting home serious discussions
um the chip shortage hit us that was
like a big problem building the actual
cluster and stuff
and you know just write the code or
whatever and yeah finally we got to
training about three months ago and yeah
got the model done like in the last
couple weeks and now push for release
so the
cluster you you built a cluster for this
model it's not like there was one
available but you actually had to get
hardware and so on it's pretty cool like
how does that work together with a
hardware sponsor like core weave so guru
reef have been really great to us uh
this wouldn't have been possible without
them
um basically after we released the pile
about a year ago and we kind of first
had some variety or whatever um core we
either december or january i don't
exactly remember when we first
approached us but they kind of first
approached us and they're like hey uh
let's do this like you know we want to
get into
large model training for our customers
anyways we don't and we would like if
you guys like test our hardware to like
help us find the right configurations of
hardware it was kind of like a it's kind
of like a back and forth kind of like
you know we give them you know free
testing fear free advice free consulting
in in return uh we had to use the
cluster to build big models and release
them
so like there was no financial yeah it
was great uh you know no financial
exchange either way it was just you know
both helping each other
so and you said sorry you said you
really you delay the release of the of
the model the weights for seven days due
to your sponsors like what what's that
like why why seven days
uh they asked for an exclusivity period
so people tried using yeah okay that's
basically it i mean it's just kind of
the initial press bomb
boost
leads them i mean i tried it so it
worked
yeah so
um you know
we thought this was a very reasonable
thing that we think doesn't like is like
a big compromise on our values or
anything here you know
we our paper isn't finished yet anyway
so we probably would have delayed it
anyways
because we haven't finished our writing
our paper uh which we want
uh to release the same time as we
release the model so this costs us
basically nothing it's good marketing
for our friends everyone wins
excellent uh give us a bit of a
like just the dimensions of the model
right here 20 b is like we've heard no
like we're accustomed almost to this
billion parameter models uh what is it
like
scale of hardware scale of of just stuff
that goes into it what what is it like
so
uh the 20b model was trained on 96 a100s
uh all interconnected with sbx4
you know nv switch interconnect and hdr
infiniband so this is all super high end
data center quality hardware that's one
of the things we learned while building
the cluster and why we had built an
actual cluster is at first you know
where we have korea it has like a
ridiculous number of gpus like one of
the biggest crypto miners and they you
know provide like gpus for like lots of
like other services and what else and so
they have a thousand and thousand
thousands of gpus unfortunately the kind
of c gpus you might use for crypto
mining or first cloud gaming or for
something like this are usually a single
you know like single pcie type
gpus and those will not work for these
large kinds of models where the
bottleneck is really the
um the communication between the
individual chips so you need this really
low latency infiniband you know
you know gpu to gpu direct interconnects
and stuff if you want to have any hope
of you know training these things so you
know we we tried like a bunch of like
demo nodes that like didn't have envy
switch or it didn't have infiniband or
whatever we kind of really worked our
way up
and ultimately really this is the only
thing that was possible and that's where
we had like kind of build it this way so
it was trained for three months on 96
a100s which is quite a lot of quite a
lot of compute and now the final model
if you want to use it for inference um
it should run fine on any uh so any card
any gpu with about 48 gigabytes of
memory or so so it runs on an a6000 or
an a40
cool excellent um so the the model we'll
get into a little bit of the results
right here there's not too much yet
there's a press release your paper is
going to come out the model as we said
are going to come out in about a week or
so from time of where we record this but
you have released some of the results
can you give us maybe like a summary of
the results maybe something that was
surprising to you or
um especially noteworthy
yeah so there's definitely a few
interesting things that happened during
the training and also with the eval
results so one funny thing what happened
is during the training uh our emails
were really bad um and we were
kind of disappointed but it turns out we
actually had a bug in our code in like
one of the operations the fuse softmax
the way it was implemented caused it to
give you bad results if you don't use
the full context length for some reason
so the training was actually totally
fine and once we fixed that bug all over
all of our um benchmarks jumped by like
three or four percent so that was nice
uh so
the way the uh results currently look is
the way i describe it is it's a
little less good at like natural
language than maybe you would expect of
a model of this size but it is like a
good bit better at like knowledge
this makes sense given the amount of the
kind of data we've trained on you know
we train a lot of code we trained on a
lot of scientific papers and medical
papers so one of the things we did
different in this model is we actually
use a different tokenizer so that's why
you know like comparing loss it doesn't
make sense to compare like complexity or
loss to the other mosques why we show
like these um you know accuracy numbers
uh
so we use a tokenizer that we trained on
the pile and also we have like a bunch
of like custom tokens or like multiple
white space to like make code more
efficient so we tried like a bunch of
different things which in retrospect we
should have tried everything at once for
the big model we probably should have
done more ablations before we started if
we have one piece of advice to people
building big models do ablations do
hyper parameter sweeps on small models
really really do that that's really
really important
so
yeah so it's the final result um
i'm generally pretty happy you know it's
not gpt3 level of course not because you
know davinci is a huge ass model and a
really very very well designed model um
it compares pretty favorably i think in
most tasks it's not uh it doesn't knock
anything really apart i would say it's
pretty good it has a lot of very good
knowledge very good scientific knowledge
um i haven't tried it yet very
extensively myself to give you like a
subjective impression of how it works
and one thing worth mentioning is the uh
hello swag results which are just weird
we don't really know why they are so low
like the hella swag results specifically
are like much lower than we would have
expected them to be yeah uh we do not
have an explanation for why that is okay
short interjection conor actually told
me later that they've mixed up two of
these numbers which means that hella
swag actually performs quite well yet it
is the wsc that is not really explained
why it's so bad they suspect that it's
the data set because jptj was already
kind of bad on that model but we don't
know
yet to be seen
but it seems it seems that on on the
what you call standard language modeling
tasks it kind of holds
holds itself you know holds par with
let's say fair sec or so um is a bit
behind da vinci and then on the factual
knowledge tasks it it is quite a bit
better than something like fair sec
right yeah is that is that a function of
because there is i don't know do you
know fair sec what kind of data it was
trained on
i don't know off the top of my head okay
because there might be like a trade-off
between you know model size may be
responsible for some things and then
data size or quality or nature might be
responsible for another thing it's
pretty cool
yeah so i expect this to probably be
down to the data so because yeah just
the way the pile is built up and like
because we also have tokenizer
specialized for the pile it's like the
original gp2 token so
honestly no one knows what tokenize
tokenizers actually affect like no one
has done any good studies on what
different tokenizers do whether large or
small vocabularies are useful whether
you want
whether having words in your uh you know
dictionary or is good or bad like no one
knows this is all guessing basically and
um
so like for example our tokenizer has
like you know really long medical terms
and single tokens in it but you know
sometimes lacks like some common you
know words you might see in a book or
something in this
uh unlike other models so
i'm not too surprised that our model
does pretty good on scientific things
which is generally i think something
we're interested in um i'm pretty sure
if you would fine tune it you would
probably get really good results for
other tasks as well so like so you know
it's always important to caveat that
this is you know an untuned model this
is a generally trained model
um it can still be fine-tuned and yeah
we'd also don't know the best sampling
parameters or whatever yet so i i'm sure
people get a lot more performance same
thing what's happened with gptj when it
first came out when for gpga first came
out it was horrible like every time you
used it for anything it was just awful
and then we turned and for some reason
it's like
uh gt3 is pretty decent if you have it
at temperature one it's like not that
bad but for some reason gptj just hates
that and you have to turn down the
temperature like 0.8 otherwise it will
it's just awful yeah i can't explain why
it's just
models have personality
and so there is there is this difference
right there's gpt j which i understand
is a jax implementation gpt neo x has
like a different code base and the x is
also an iteration on gpt neo which was
sort of your first project uh can you
explain us a little bit are these
different people working on the
different things like why did you why
isn't there a gpt j20b um so what's
what's the reasoning behind sort of
building these models choosing the code
bases choosing what technologies to use
so it's mostly all by necessity so we
started with gpt neo when we only had
access to tpus from the
tenants flow research cloud as our sole
compute
uh neo is an incredibly cursed code base
and should never be used by anyone
so neo is fully deprecated do not use
neo we do not support neo we do not
don't even look at it
um
is a offshoot in the sense so yes it is
written completely in jax but it's done
basically exclusively by ben wang uh he
basically just did that by himself
absolute matlab so it's kind of like an
offshoot of the luther ai project so
like so it's like a different type
different people worked on that than
worked on neo
um the reason there was no uh j20b is
that
um
mtj so the the actual code used to train
6b in my if i remember incorrectly lack
certain kinds of parallelisms that you
would want for these large channels you
can do it like we've tested it it does
kind of work but it's uh pretty slow and
we just can't reliably get enough tpus
to actually make that happen so
like you know we can get you know
we got like
with 6b you know we just got just enough
gpus i think it was 256 for like three
weeks or so and you know that took its
time and it's very dependent on how much
cpus google is currently using
internally whether we get access to some
because they're all preemptable yeah so
we moved to ux which is written in pi
torch um because we got gpus which is
much nicer than tpus so yeah that's
basically the whole reason for that so
the people that worked on the ux are
basically kind of the same people who
worked on neo so big shout outs in
particular to sid black who is like you
know the
figurehead for most of the neo projects
also of course uh too many people to
name but there's a lot of other people
who have also contributed a lot
um it's it's it's it's pretty cool
to see like
like different technologies matter
because people are always like well you
know do you prefer tensorflow or pie
torch or jackson people are like you
know whatever you want like whatever
fits but
as soon as you get to like these
frontiers of engineering it actually
matters um kind of i mean you could
probably as you said implement anything
in anything but there the differences
between can i do parallelism can i do
you know this or that how easily can i
do it uh it's cool to see that there's
still kind of a distinction between
stuff and it's not just all like the
same um
my question is a bit
as you train this big model you said
ablations on small models you know to
know your hyper parameters
how much
hand holding is required for the big
models like how often do you have to
like stop training change something and
then continue from where you stopped or
this does not happen at all do you just
restart and hope for you know better
luck with some other parameters
so with 20b we didn't have any like
terrible
problems like things diverging and stuff
like that we of course did a lot of
testing with high parameters whatever
but honestly could have done much more
and
uh
like i i again i can't it's like large
model training is very much alchemy like
you think ml is alchemy this is the
alchemy of the alchemy like it is very
much secret recipes of like like for
example you know knowing that you set
the atom beta 2 parameter to 0.95
instead of 99 is really important yeah
like if you don't set it to nine five if
you sent to nine nine which is the
default it you can't train large models
like it's like way more unstable
and like you would never come on that's
common knowledge oh yeah
everyone would know these
things so yeah it's just like and like
there's like so much of it is like
folklore too like um i remember someone
asked someone at opening ai like why do
they use weight decay and the answer was
because al redford said it helps
like that's the that's the whole reason
why people use weight decay is because
it helps isn't there also like a
difference between i believe isn't there
a difference between uh like the atom
parameters in the different frameworks
like the default parameters and yeah
this
yeah i think that is true i don't know
about the top of my head but yeah so
like there's there's a lot of like
little details like that that don't
matter as much as smaller networks but
can't really matter in large networks so
20b i think it's kind of like on the
frontier of models that are still
trainable in reasonable circumstances
yeah for example the big science project
from hugging face has been having an
absolute hell of a time trying to train
100 billion parameter model and it just
keeps diverging and then they roll it
back and try something else and it
diverges in here roll it back and we
didn't have to do that with 20b
20b was
actually pretty well behaved all things
considered once we had a you know set of
parameters down and a pretty decent
dataset also very important dataset
really matters like it really really
meant even the pile is like
we could do better now in retrospect
we're seeing like there's like a lot of
things like de-duping and stuff that we
could have done yeah that we think would
improve it quite a lot so i remember for
example the big science project once had
this like huge divergence that like keep
happening and then they looked into the
data set and they found that it was like
uh 500 000 backslashes just consecutive
it was turning on
i mean you gotta you gotta see it right
if you see if you're gonna you yeah it's
better than 4chan i guess um
so people can try out this model if they
go to
say aye you can make you can make a an
account and you can play around with it
a little bit it's it is the default
model currently right here um
i tried hello and it did give me
some code
yeah it gives me some code again
um do you do
you said you haven't played around with
it much but um is like what what kind of
what kind of stuff would you expect to
work nicely
anything do i have to set now the
temperature to point a
i have no idea so like i'm just saying
like that's how it was with jay i don't
know knee x's personality so i expect
people to you know still find you know
better better you know parameters also
like the you know the playground because
ai is brand new so i'm sure they're
going to add like more features like
repetition penalty and stuff which helps
um so what i would expect in us to be
best at is uh code and like scientific
tasks yeah like you know
um it's like for example i used to know
a doctor who used like jay and our neo
models to give him ideas for new
research topics yeah he would like
prompt like you know i uh you are a
brilliant medical epidemiologist working
in the field of xyz and you are going to
study and then examine came up with
really interesting experiments i know
that's like a common use case or
whatever but i would expect that to work
i'm sure it's fine at like you know uh
you know story generation and stuff like
that i would expect it like fine-tuning
uh it on on more of those tags will
probably make it a lot better
um
and but yeah it's it's knowledge should
be pretty good it should be pretty
decent in coding not as good as codex or
god forbid alpha code of course
but i would expect it to be pretty
decent at all these tasks and this is
still um
this is still language modeling so this
is still like uh likelihood next token
prediction this isn't any contrastive
training or anything like this yep yep
this is
just plain gpt3 type training nice cool
is there anything else you you want to
shout out about this model people
uh
code anything
well i guess i just wanted to say you
know
thanks to the luther eye people also
like to uh shout out uh maybe annelanton
and um
aaron who is their ceo who has been very
instrumental including some of his
employees have been really instrumental
in helping with this so this wasn't just
illusory ai we also got a lot of help
from
them and some of the cluster stuff and
there as you can see they're also a
partner on the goose ai project so we're
very thankful for their help um it's
been quite the right it's been good fun
we don't intend to stop here if you're
if you're interested in illusory ai in
the kind of work we do or if you're an
academic or a researcher that wants to
work on this kind of model we love to
hear from you check out our discord
love to hear from you
connor thank you very much for being
with us